hé
Johnny, à quel point l'école va être nulle,
tu n'aimeras pas ça, à quel point c'est mauvais de se
faire écraser les couilles
si fort qu'elles ne deviennent qu'une seule connerie, [ __ ] de merde,
tu devrais aller à l'école tous
les jours avec John, non merci, tu aurais peut-être dû
amusant non je ne m'amuserais pas je guette la
maison quand vous êtes
sortis [musique] ce qui est arrivé à la télé c'était un
accident tu vas à l'école et
tu vas développer un [ __ ] de cerveau oh
allez si je le faisais
Je sais que je suis hé DG, tu amènes tes
poupées à l'école, c'est les années 90, les temps
changent, l'éducation sexuelle, commençons
par la masturbation, si tu dois
donner des devoirs, Johnny l'a déjà fait
ce matin, tu la fermes,
mec, je ne l'ai pas fait.  j'ai fumé je n'ai pas eu de relations sexuelles
je n'ai pas eu de petite amie je vais la
perdre toi et moi avons été les meilleurs
amis toute notre vie nous sommes sur le point de nous
défoncer pour la première fois pouvons-nous
prendre de la drogue s'il vous plaît faisons-le  c'est
vrai,
oh
mec, pouvez-vous croire que nous aimons avoir
une expérience et une expérience en
réalité, y a-t-il une [ __ ] de fuite de gaz ou
quelque chose de joli costume F face, il est
possible que vous ne soyez pas tous les deux
complètement
foutus, regardez longuement, c'est quoi
la vie est une [ __ ] de merde Teddy, je suis la dernière
vierge à l'école, nous pouvons arranger ça, je dois
trouver un pénis frais en feu, prends ton
pénis frais ici, Jésus-Christ a toujours cette
odeur de nouveau pénis, tu la fermes, d'accord,
j'essaie juste de
[Musique  ]
aide